at its height the roman empire was home
to about 30 percent of the world's
population and in many ways it was the
pinnacle of human advancement
its citizens enjoyed the benefits of
central heating concrete double glazing
banking international trade and upward
social mobility
rome became the first city in history
with one million inhabitants and was a
center of technological legal and
economic progress
an empire impossible to topple stable
and rich and powerful
until it wasn't anymore
first slowly then suddenly the most
powerful civilization on earth collapsed
by civilization we mean a complex
society where labour is specialized and
social classes emerge and which is ruled
by institutions
civilizations share a dominant mutual
language and culture and domesticate
plants and animals to feed and sustain
large cities where they often construct
impressive monuments
civilization lets us become efficient on
large scales collect vast amounts of
knowledge and put human ingenuity and
the natural resources of the world to
work
without civilization most people would
never have been born
which makes it a bit concerning that
collapse is the rule not the exception
virtually all civilizations end on
average after 340 years
collapse is really nice for individuals
their shared cultural identity is
shattered as institutions lose the power
to organize people
knowledge is lost living standards fall
violence increases and often the
population declines
the civilization either completely
disappears is absorbed by stronger
neighbors or something new emerges
sometimes with more primitive technology
than before
if this is how it's been over the ages
what about us today
[Music]
just as europeans forgot how to build
indoor plumbing and make cement will we
lose our industrial technology and with
that our greatest achievements from one
dollar pizza to smartphones or laser eye
surgery will all this go away too
today our cities stretch for thousands
of square kilometers we travel the skies
our communication is instant
industrial agriculture with engineered
high-yield plants efficient machinery
and high potency fertilizer feeds
billions of people
modern medicine gives us the longest
lifespan we've ever had while industrial
technology gives us an unprecedented
level of comfort and abundance even
though we haven't yet learned to attain
them without destroying our ecosphere
there are arguably still different
civilizations around today that compete
and co-exist with each other but
together they also form a singular
global civilization
but this modern globalized civilization
is even more vulnerable in some ways
than past empires because we are much
more deeply interconnected
a collapse of the industrialized world
literally means that the majority of
people alive today would perish since
without industrial agriculture we would
no longer be able to feed them
and there's an even greater risk
what if a collapse was so deeply
destructive that we were unable to
reindustrialize again
what if it ruined our chances of
enjoying a flourishing future as a
multi-planetary species
a global civilizational collapse could
be an existential catastrophe something
that ruins not just the lives of
everyone alive today but all the future
generations that could have come into
being
all the knowledge we might have
discovered the art we might have created
the joys we might have experienced would
be lost
so how likely is all of this
let's start with some good news
while civilization collapses have
happened regularly none have ever
derailed the course of global
civilization
rome collapsed but the axomite empire or
the tier tier juans and of course the
byzantine empire carried on
what about sudden population crashes
so far we've not seen a catastrophe that
has killed much more than 10 percent of
the global population no pandemic no
natural disaster no war
the last clear example of a rapid global
population decrease was the black death
a pandemic of the bubonic plague in the
14th century that spread across the
middle east and europe and killed a
third of all europeans and about
one-tenth of the global population
if any event was going to cause the
collapse of civilization that should
have been it
but even the black death demonstrates
humanity's resilience more than its
fragility
while the old societies were massively
disrupted in the short term the intense
loss of human lives and suffering did
little to negatively impact european
economic and technological development
in the long run
population size recovered within two
centuries and just two centuries later
the industrial revolution began
history is full of incredible recoveries
from horrible tragedies
take the atomic bombing of hiroshima
during world war ii
140 000 people were killed and 90 of the
city was at least partially incinerated
or reduced to rubble
but against all odds they made a
remarkable recovery
hiroshima's population recovered within
a decade and today it's a thriving city
of 1.2 million people
none of this made these horrible events
any less horrible for those who live
through them but for us as a species
these signs of resilience are good news
why recovery is likely even in the worst
case
one thing that's different from historic
collapses is that humanity now has
unprecedented destructive power
today's nuclear arsenals are so powerful
that all-out global war could cause a
nuclear winter and billions of deaths
our knowledge of our own biology and how
to manipulate it is getting so advanced
that it's becoming possible to engineer
viruses as contagious as the coronavirus
and as deadly as ebola
increasingly the risk of global
pandemics is much higher than in the
past
so we may cause a collapse ourselves and
it might be much worse than the things
nature has thrown at us so far
but if say 99 of the population died
would global civilization collapse
forever could we recover from such a
tragedy
we have some reasons to be optimistic
let's start with food
there are 1 billion agricultural workers
today so even if the global population
fell to just 80 million it's virtually
guaranteed that many survivors would
know how to produce food and we don't
need to start at square one because we
could still use modern high-yield crops
maize is ten times bigger than its wild
ancestor
ancient tomatoes were the size of
today's peas
after agriculture the next step towards
recovery would be rebuilding industrial
capacity like power grids and automated
manufacturing
a huge problem is that our economies of
scale make it impossible to just pick up
where we left off
many of our high-tech industries are
only functional because of huge demand
and intensely interconnected supply
chains across different continents
even if our infrastructure were left
unharmed we would make huge steps
backwards technologically but then again
we are thinking in larger time frames
industrialization originally happened 12
000 years after the agricultural
revolution
so if we need to start over after a
massive collapse it shouldn't be that
hard to reindustrialize at least on
evolutionary time scales
there's a hitch though the industrial
revolution was fueled literally by
burning easily accessible coal and we
are still very much reliant on it
if we use it all up today aside from
making rapid climate change much worse
we could hinder our ability to recover
from a huge crisis
so we should stop using easy to access
coal so it can serve as a civilization
insurance in case something bad happens
another thing that makes recovery likely
is that we probably have most of the
information we need to rebuild
civilization we would certainly lose a
lot of crucial institutional knowledge
especially on hard drives that nobody
could read or operate anymore but a lot
of the technological scientific and
cultural knowledge stored in the world's
2.6 million libraries would survive the
catastrophe
the post-collapse survivors would know
what used to be possible and they could
reverse engineer some of the tools and
machines they'd find
in conclusion despite the bleak prospect
of catastrophic threats natural or
created by ourselves there is reason for
optimism humankind is remarkably
resilient and even in the case of a
global civilizational collapse it seems
likely that we would be able to recover
even if many people were to perish or
suffer immense hardship
even if we lost cultural and
technological achievements in the
process
but given the stakes the risks are still
unnervingly high
nuclear war and dangerous pandemics
threaten the amazing global civilization
we have built
humanity is like a teenager speeding
around blind corners drunk without a
seatbelt
the good news is that it's still early
enough to prepare for and to mitigate
these risks we just need to actually do
it
we made this video together with will
mccaskill a professor of philosophy at
oxford and one of the founders of the
effective altruism movement which is
about doing the most good you can with
your time and money will just published
a new book called what we owe the future
which is about how you can positively
impact the long-term future of our world
if you like kotzkazak videos the chances
are high you'll like it
the book has some pretty
counter-intuitive arguments like the
risks from new technologies such as ai
and synthetic biology are at least as
grave as those from climate change or
that the world doesn't contain too many
people but too few
and especially that everyday actions
like recycling or refusing to fly just
aren't that big a deal compared to where
you donate or what career you pursue
most importantly it argues that by
acting wisely you can help make tomorrow
better than today and how we together
can build a flourishing world for the
thousands or millions of generations
that will come after us
many things we at kotskazak talk about
regularly are discussed here in much
greater detail check out what we owe the
future wherever you get your books or
audiobooks
did we manage to unlock a new fear for
you
let's counter existential dread with
appreciation for humanity
look how far we've come as a species
what we've built and where we've
gathered
let this new world map poster be a
reminder of what we can achieve
[Music]
[Music]
you